this is what's left of the house where
abu bakr al-baghdadi was hiding the
images were filmed for sky news just
hours after the u.s special forces night
time raid
locals still picking through the rubble
the bodies still being collected
and eyewitnesses with details of it all
i opened the door of my house and saw a
helicopter in front of me no more than
15 meters in the air
and another one right behind it they
were circling around two kilometers
there were no shots fired at first and
then suddenly there was gunfire and the
helicopter began firing back
around 70 u.s soldiers and a number of
military dogs were involved
on the ground they blew holes in the
wall of the building to avoid
booby trap doors the mission to locate
and kill baghdadi
lasted about two hours then the whole
compound was destroyed
the 90-minute raid began early on sunday
morning near the syrian town of barisha
in idlib province right next to the
turkish border
u.s forces used eight helicopters to
approach baghdadi's compound
they flew low and fast from a location
not yet revealed for an hour and ten
minutes
taking gunfire as they got closer
u s special forces then engaged in a
gunfight and breached the is leaders
hideout
blasting holes in the wall we're told
baghdadi tried to escape through a
tunnel network
along with three children but the is
leader became cornered
in what the u.s president described as a
dead end
it's here where the americans say he
detonated his suicide vest
the explosion killed him three children
and caused the tunnel to collapse
the location is in an area controlled
not by the islamic state but by a
separate al-qaeda-affiliated group
and it's surrounded by areas controlled
by the russians the turkish
syrian government forces and by the
kurds
the american president said they all
played a part but didn't know about the
specifics of the operation
iraqi intelligence is thought to have
been key as well as critical help from
the syrian kurds
during the last few months we followed
several leads also
regarding allah baghdadi and several
isis
leaders in different places which led us
eventually to
know exactly where al-baghdadi was
the islamic state pattern has been to
reform to strike
back after a setback and that's the big
concern here
up to 70 000 of his followers remain in
camps in northern syria
he is gone but his ideology is not
mark stone sky news